wenn ich nach Hause komme dann sehe ich
durchs Fenster wenn sich hier sitzt ist
ein guter Tag ja wenn Sie hier nicht ist
dann ist immer die Frage ist sie hier
unten auf der Couch liegt so oben im
Bett und wenn so oben im Bett liegt ist
der Roller runter oder ist der Rollo
hoch wenn der Rolle runter ist dann wird
es kein schöner schöner Abend mehr
danke für deine Hilfe
Jennifer leidet an mcfs einer schweren
neuroimmunologischen Erkrankung dass sie
seither bei vielen Aktivitäten nicht
mehr dabei sein kann daran mussten sich
ihr Mann Christian und die zwei Töchter
nach und nach gewöhnen
ohne Christian würde Jennifer ihren
Alltag kaum bewältigen
jede Bewegung für die 43-Jährige einen
Kraftakt von dem sie sich lange erholen
muss dazu ständige Schmerzen
Muskulatur Stoffwechselkreislauf
funktioniert einfach nicht mehr sagt
Jennifer vor eineinhalb Jahren brach bei
ihr im CFS aus
ich lag immer im Bett mit Herzrasen mit
Herzrhythmusstörungen mit Schmerzen in
der Brust ich hatte Schmerzen
wahnsinnige Schmerzen in den Armen in
den Beinen ich konnte die nicht mehr
alleine hochheben ich konnte nicht mehr
alleine aufstehen mein Mann hat mich
noch mit einem Schreibtischstuhl am
Anfang ins Bad geschoben weil ich diesen
Weg das sind drei Meter ins Badezimmer
nicht mehr alleine geschafft habe und
ich war so verzweifelt weil ich einfach
auch nicht wusste was ist denn mit mir
los
35 Medikamente nimmt Jennifer täglich um
die Symptome dieser schweren Erkrankung
zu lindern eine Heilung ist bei mcfs
bisher nicht möglich ihre Arbeit als
Managerin musste sie aufgeben es war ein
langer Kampf um die richtige Diagnose
denn mcfs ist kaum erforscht und auch
nur wenige Ärzte wissen Bescheid
insbesondere in den ersten Monaten war
das furchtbar weil ich komplett alleine
gelassen da stand und das was ich
rausgefunden habe habe ich auf eigene
Initiative rausgefunden und das habe ich
nicht durch den Arzt rausgefunden meine
Frau die hat Türen eingerannt bei Ärzten
die aber trotzdem verschlossen bleiben
und aufgrund der Tatsache dass die Ärzte
nicht damit umzugehen wissen schieben
die das früher oder später alle die
psychosomatische Ecke natürlich eine
43-jährige Mutter die sich nicht um ihre
Kinder kümmern kann
die hat dann auch irgendwann damit
psychisch zu kämpfen aber der Ursprung
ist nicht psychosomatisch
bei Jennifer war es die corona-impfung
die mecfs auslöste
diagnostiziert wurde das genauso wie
ihre mecfs-erkrankung in der Uniklinik
Marburg
die corona-impfung könne bei manchen
mecfs auslösen meistens sei aber eine
Virusinfektion verantwortlich sagt
Professor Schiefer auffällig sei das in
der corona-pandemie viele Erkrankte
dazugekommen sein
die nach jeder Art von
Infektionserkrankungen auftreten kann
das ist etwas das kennen wir schon seit
vielen vielen Jahren Jahrzehnten aber es
ist in dieser Dichte so wie wir es im
Moment erleben
für uns etwas völlig Neues wir sehen
dass einzelne Patienten sich mit
bestimmten Therapiemaßnahmen erholen wir
sehen aber auch dass wir manche
Patienten die zu spät kommen oder die
bestimmte immundeffekte mitbringen vor
der Entwicklung von mecfs im Moment
nicht geschützt werden können
nichtsdestotrotz sind wir da völlig am
Anfang
zu wenig Ärzte wissen über mecfs
bescheid das mussten Louis und seine
Mutter Corinna leitlich erfahren im März
trafen wir sie in der Praxis von Dr
Beate Jäger in Mülheim an der Ruhr der
19-Jährige sollte hier eine
Blutreinigung bekommen der letzte
Strohhalm sagt seine Mutter
Luis hat ständig Schmerzen kann kaum
noch laufen ist Geräusch und
lichtempfindlich auch seine Mutter fühlt
sich im Stich gelassen
es waren zwei Ärzte dabei die das nicht
verstehen konnten was er hat und warum
er damals noch Rollator gelaufen ist und
ja sind dann in die Neurologische Klinik
überwiesen worden was ich aber nicht
getan habe aus gutem Grunde weil auch da
war es schon bekannt dass die Kinder
ganz schnell auf die Kinderpsychiatrie
kommen weil es gibt keinen
Therapieansatz und das muss auch erstmal
anerkannt werden
bei Luis weiß die Infektion mit dem
Coronavirus das mecfs auslöste seit
vielen Monaten ist der Schüler komplett
aus seinem Leben gerissen
aktuelles der stand dass er ganz starke
verzöger hat Erschöpfung er kann fünf
bis zehn Sekunden am Tag vielleicht mal
stehen ansonsten ist auf dem Rollstuhl
angewiesen liegt ganz viel im Bett wenn
Besuch da war eine halbe Stunde im
Gespräch geführt haben anderthalb Tage
danach hat er einen Crash und ähm
schafft gar nichts mehr in der Schule
ist er zurzeit nicht das Abi hat leider
nicht geklappt und ja wir hoffen dass es
jetzt langsam nach der Affäre wieder
aufwärts geht
die helferese eine Art der Blutreinigung
hat Luis auch nicht geholfen
[Musik]
ihm geht es nach wie vor sehr schlecht
rund 500.000 mecfs erkrankte aber
bundesweit nur zwei spezialisierte
Anlaufstellen für Kinder in München und
die einzige für Erwachsenen Berlin
Carmen scheibenbogen sind viele
Erkrankte sehr dankbar in der Charité
forscht die Professorin ein Ursachen und
Risikofaktoren
das Epstein-Barr-Virus bekannt als
Auslöser des Pfeifferschen Drüsenfiebers
ist oft für mlcfs verantwortlich bei den
meisten bleibt das aber ohne Folgen
warum passiert das jetzt nur bei einem
Teil der Betroffenen wir wissen heute
auch dass es dafür Risikofaktoren gibt
so haben Frauen beispielsweise ein
aktiveres Immunsystem und Frauen sind
auch sehr viel häufiger von im ecfs und
postcode betroffen wir wissen auch dass
es genetische Risikofaktoren gibt für
ein besonders aktives Immunsystem in
diesem Familien treten dann häufiger
Autoimmunerkrankungen auf und auch das
ist ein
Risikofaktor für im ecfs wir kennen also
auch bestimmte Gene die zu einem
aktiveren Immunsystem führen mehr
Versorgungszentren mehr Geld für
Forschung und Behandlung mehr Ärzte die
sich auskennen fordert die Professoren
sollte da nicht und auch viele
Betroffene wie Mitte Mai vor dem
Reichstag in Berlin also müssen wir
Hilfe die wir so dringend brauchen
selbstorganisieren obwohl mecfs von der
Weltgesundheitsorganisation schon vor
mehr als 50 Jahren als neurologische
Krankheit eingestuft wurde die
Initiative liegen Demo hatte diese
Protestaktion organisiert
für Hunderttausende mecfs-
viele konnten in Berlin nicht dabei sein
rund 700 waren von zu Hause aus
zugeschaltet
[Musik]
auch die Organisatoren der Aktion die
Zahlen von 2021 nennen 500.000
Betroffene das heißt 500.000 Menschen
die medizinisch und pflegerisch
unversorgt oder nur unzureichen
es gibt in ganz Deutschland
über 200
Kompetenzzentren für Multiple Sklerose
[Musik]
wir haben zwei
das ist nicht fair
das ist ein Skandal
und deswegen brauche es dringend solche
Aktionen wie in Berlin sagt Alexandra
Hahn Sprecherin der Initiative liegen
Demo auch wenn es sie Betroffenen dies
tatsächlich hierher geschafft haben sehr
viel Kraft koste zu lange seien sie im
Stich gelassen worden die mecfs
Betroffenen bekommen häufig die Diagnose
dass es eine psychosomatische Erkrankung
ist das ist schlichtweg falsch die
Behandlung die daraufhin Folgen
verschlimmern die Symptome wir möchten
das nicht mehr lange gewartet wird es
sind über eine halbe Millionen
Betroffene darunter auch Kinder und
Jugendliche die heute die Hilfe brauchen
er will in Feist für ihren Sohn von
Frankfurt am Main nach Berlin gekommen
der 26-Jährige hatte sich mit dem
epstein-bar-virus infiziert und war kurz
danach an mcfs erkrankt unser Sohn ist
seit eineinhalb Jahren ans Bett
gefesselt und kann auch beispielsweise
keine Bücher lesen oder ohne Gehörschutz
sein das heißt er hat immer
Ohrstöpsel drin er hat am ganzen Körper
Schmerzen
Muskelschmerzen Gelenkschmerzen ich bin
quasi 24 Stunden am Tag zu Hause also
wenn mein Mann jetzt nicht arbeiten
würde dann
könnten wir nicht davon leben also das
muss man wirklich sagen da sind wir
unterversorgt komplett also ich weiß
nicht wie das andere machen die nur für
sich selber einstehen müssen die kommen
mit dieser diesem Geld was die
Pflegekasse da bereitstellt einfach
nicht zu Rande
einen Antrag zur besseren Versorgung von
mecfs-patienten hat nie Unionsparteien
gestellt Erich Elsdorfer von der CSU
findet es bedauerlich dass sich die
Koalitionsparteien nicht darauf einigen
konnten
wenn man so etwas ablehnt bin ich der
Meinung muss man einen Gegenvorschlag
kommen das ist nicht der Fall und das
finde ich sehr enttäuschend und
natürlich auch schade gerade für die
Betroffenen weil die Betroffenen haben
mit Sicherheit nicht mehr die Kraft und
die Zeit hier zu warten das sieht
grundsätzlich auch der
Patientenbeauftragte der Bundesregierung
so der unionsvorschlag habe Schwächen
gehabt gesagt Stefan schwarze gehe aber
in die richtige Richtung und eine sei
auf jeden Fall geboten wenn man sie
sieht in welcher verzweifelten lagen
manche sind
dann wird glaube ich allen deutlich mit
welcher Entschlossenheit dieses Thema
vorangetrieben werden muss ich will
meinen Teil dazu tun und ich werde in
der Bundesregierung und im Parlament
dafür werden dass alle anderen auch
mitmachen
und dass wir gemeinsam eine Verbesserung
der Versorgung und der Behandlung der
Betroffenen erreichen
eine der Rednerinnen bei der liegen Demo
in Berlin war Jasna Fritzi Bauer auch
ihre Mutter ist dann MLC festerkrankt in
Berlin las die Schauspielerin die
Botschaften von Erkrankten vor die nicht
kommen konnten
meine Organe versagen immer mehr die
Blase ist gelähmt der Magen und der Darm
sind gelähmt das Herz ist angegriffen
ich merke dass meine Kräfte zu Ende
gehen ich möchte noch nicht sterben ich
brauche dringend Hilfe und sie liest aus
einem Brief ihrer schwerkranken Mutter
vor mittlerweile erhalte ich volle
Erwerbsminderungsrente und habe
Pflegestufe 2 im Schnitt liege ich 22
Stunden des Tages im Bett
jasnas Mutter Kathrin lebt in Wiesbaden
bei der 55-Jährigen war es das
Epstein-Barr-Virus das mecfs auslöste
seit knapp vier Jahren spielt sich das
Leben der dreifachen Mutter fast nur zu
Hause ab
meistens liegend wie viele mecfs
Erkrankte leidet auch Katrin an einer
extremen belastungsintoleranz wenn ich
duschen möchte muss ich mir das
einteilen weil das hat eine ganz schwere
Aufgabe ist für mich eine körperliche
schwere Aufgabe
Haushalt geht gar nicht eigentlich also
wenn ich ein Zimmer staubsauge muss ich
mich danach ins Bett legen für zwei
Stunden und merke auch am nächsten Tag
dass das einfach zu viel war
den Rollstuhl hatte sich Katrin
eigentlich zugelegt um herauszukommen
doch sie musste feststellen dass sie
auch dafür die Kraft fehlt Katrin Weine
lebenslustige sportliche Frau die
alleinerziehende Mutter wollte gerade
jetzt da die Töchter wachsen sind in
ihrem Job als Redakteuren durchstarten
ihre Pläne und Träume musste sie
begraben ja dann geht halt echt einen
Film ab weil du dann weißt okay du
kannst nicht mehr arbeiten wo kommt das
Geld her was ist mit deinem Leben ich
musste ganz viele Dinge die ich geplant
hatte absagen sowieso schon und das war
so eine ganz große Trauer jedes Mal also
auch so ein Verlust das war schon sehr
sehr schwer momentan muss ich sagen
auch Katrin wünscht sich deutlich mehr
Forschung und Anerkennung für diese
schwere Krankheit nur so hätten
Betroffene überhaupt eine Chance auf die
richtige angemessene Behandlung
mir geht's ja noch gut vergleichsweise
es gibt also schwerst betroffene
Menschen die leben in abgedunkelten
Zimmern die können keine Geräusche
ertragen die können kein Licht ertragen
wie ertragen keine Berührung die können
nicht mehr alleine essen müssen
künstliche ernährt werden und
vegetieren in ihren Zimmern vor sich hin
und viele dieser schwer betroffenen
haben auch tatsächlich schon zur
Verfügung mit oder Verträge mit
sterbehilfen dass sie sagen wenn Besuche
weiterzumachen aber wenn ich nicht mehr
kann möchte ich wissen dass es dann auch
gut ist und ich dann auch sagen kann das
was und das ist schon das ist schon hart
Katrin Bauer hat für sich die Hoffnung
noch nicht aufgegeben auch wenn es
mittlerweile vier Jahre sind in denen
sie kaum Besserung erfahren hat
[Musik]
Jennifer Wieners aus Königstein ist
dankbar dass sie ihren Mann Christian
immer an ihrer Seite hat
in die Öffentlichkeit zu gehen habe sie
sehr viel Kraft gekostet sagt sie aber
nur so könne Sie etwas bewegen die Zeit
des stillen Leidens vieler mlcfs
Betroffener sollte endlich ein Ende
haben